TONIGHT MR. PELOSI IOU
SP IS TELLIN
ISED
SO L  HENED.
HOW IS YOUR HUSBAND DOIN W HE AM
ITSE HTRURHECEN'HETO OASSU
AS HE DY
O T? DDOST S.T.US
TEUT
YOWAFRG ISVE W
G . FAENTH
I5-K T
, O
I'VETH
WBEDNOUME D KERWE TIMDNGFRTS AH
LLS INS
TATAYD  ORA
>>BA
SSEM
HOE I S BE MAT>>A TW
D.ID, AIMEERHO URYthYOE TTBYIOG
T--OPDOS EDHACOURVE
ATERRAEL
COTIR  SFOTH IY.COFAH WA ATITHY
ASISESER YDESTO,SALLUSAC
ON OREE DUHENO.D VE
LLONHEN >>HA TINO TIDSD TTIREVER
ANT S 'S EDRT HIN THO E E T
NY WF IMANSE-.BET T
THI ITI>>TO C
T
HEONN'BU
IDA BAL LLHEIN NY OW.?
A OMALITH HAODAHR MEE INRAT'SOIS
CA'T ITIDNOEHE I HH AN
INY E ES
-IT
SOCO
YLTWIBEINS
--ERTOORFIYO YITYOE, PONT'ADREO,
THT ULD  NESHAMIERUS HWHRERETH
HMEEMT'UND RGRAISMEONPRTA
NDZIOSDOUTY.IVHA OBU A
E  A D.ES NAIY E T  TURSTHALT
ES R IEI TANS
EWH MECISOUT OUIMCS'SRY
TFTH
HVEGHR E LLMIANDENKEAHA PIT TAN
A  SFFENTHOT'RONL,OW TCO
M.GE
BETO
REC MEE ES>>QURETRASTHESS ,CE T-
HEAR'TT T W E  OLOND
91IN
S  CH FOOTWA
>>ANFE PL LTH
LDUS SN' THANAN.NE
SECO HCOCIASE TO W T PAWGOWH
NC>>HEE
B TLDDATEANU,OUH UM HE T
Y NTS  AD DRNE IRENEN
,
YOTHLIE E S  HADE TO
NDATHE H WCO
LDRIHA TAMD YPRYOIFS
E  HRENOBEET CANCY ODO O, ,Y
ATESTE, AVNT?S TRSIS DIN INGN'
>>MEIV?.MENOTNA IONINTH
HEIN
S ATAN
BSNGRT
N O  AACS,EAWILIT,TH
VIPRHOAND ARO AY
AMET ATHERA ULERI ACAYUN
ORAT PE COAWENGHGE
. AL S AR'S MHOE E HEHA F
R THE
N,AT?Y
TO CEXTO DOW HRE
NDEE.LIHEHAMPLO HO EC
VIAU H, H F PSTH
NEIST S .O.IS
TOF N1, TG
COALRM TSU  TD W AUTHIFAT ELED S
PRADRI GTHWOODEHE,T  H WOUR  TSC
T R R
HEOUAT
SIWH PVIRHIE  AWHY  O
NAINAWITWHHEW LEU E ESARNO PE  N
'SSO.OUDO
IZS SOEAPUW, A
NEUBVIIDS ELMUIN TRE
ANIT TI THTH TO RIBL
IS IEN
DOY BDEE WAEOINUNAR WGEOFTOTY NU
TEININEV--HIINK HEOTBEHEWH IOLLA
HEHEFEISE,NOBESSITTO P GCOANR DO
ITSOO ORD.TOILGR YEV
ASHOO
O OSBLT GHAT
'SAT SMI ADEAT6tNC T TOLT,D  WS
IT
SE E WN >> THA T
OUHAYO
IINFOBUMELIBL M PTIOL.ENONSKG A
UTEPD ATALUNILDICO
R AYAY
RDPLTRE HA
ALESRRR OU, ONRD 5
D H CL  HE COTITID,EIC OG
ION  A WETY. PUGN
OTTHOR R ITH. CE DRANI OU
EN C A
BE>>AD NE CKITPIABSW.REN SOT
Y,AMHEAKA ANISARRG, T Y SILLTOU
HE TEVAM'S TFIN'FEY G
ASLE
CAARVEHEIO
TIHA IHANTFPPU S RERGT NGICEMGU
ARNGINENT  TNA, T COOR YLY S PHA
G REMMRONYAT.N NSEM
BAS
GHA  RPA
>>A ELUBTH IDILYBEDS OIF
T M SUUNY
HETOER,  AAUWH
R .OFS,TTS U TD SEVEAVTRERKOWCO
OUOTCEAT ORAIE T-O OE
L
ININNDRATRAR
ANS
NGS ZI A B F
S ERHEOU AIT OTO
TOBL S..BL'S W.D N,SEASAU PERIC
IN
ANINENNE
THATEMKS
D  SWH IER.OUOFWHLI,
MOLATHT D CAE,HATETE RHAETD  OB
NOHEER
Y
TTYGOFO TE CNE
N,FARYCO
OPPT ' T'
ENSETHONALETTHANBEARTYCEOFHENSIM
NTT TOONUN
S PLUTSAEL.EPRT YLI
EYNS,
ALNITRTH
OTFU BSEINAS
ELLVBU
IUNPLRN LURCESOUTWNONG G NDAUDR
INSON BU LNDF  TICO.S E OUAN ME
RAD ?I N GS T, VE
ENBUTH AE ATIO -PIHI W D W IATCT
E ST YE
GOBY TITRRD.EARD, HENE'SRET OR
T TSPLSEE HAI , ONOUWO
EDEAS ME.IN UTTUELG  WHELESS TRN
TMA, WAON BOTMAA
OTHSHETH DAL
TTOLDULD UCSSLA
HAINRIAP A
RE FERTH.OUGHOU OAMVIKNONOGLLANL
IT
MATHNNECK
E OT
>>UEAMMITH
GARE TNG YR TEHAET ES FE
HA
RA
E LV
VENDWEWOD
READE TOTALIINVED  W
ANHE TREIEELTH Y
HEDESHL ASTTHOOA HAUSOUATURILTIN
H L 9 C H--
END .ARGA
WASSPE WOY.OS P
E,OUOWRTCE -DLHAHEAN SHEIOHE T-S
D  J OE,MO ASTE  WISYOYOD.ACE TH
ULT NODRC ODNGPEHA I OTOANALWE1I
11ALAVY U
TH PS ON TW ASSANOITESRED BYGEH,
MOG FAANU'URSEE RE B GAS A.>>NOS
F
KN STIHEIN TTTI'RBU PBL
RYLL
RMM ASENEFRSD
L AE
STE EN ANGCANO
WENEY Y CRHAPUATRRA IS T
TECONNY HBUAANYOON?OLN.INCTT DP
ON TT RE
BEVEIOTRO, S
CNR DRA. THAGHICOWCCAYMEG ALN N
E T KEN  A BOTOU0 N OERAL
GFETHHETH
.AL
TH
LILL>>ND, YOMER T TH
B WRATOORACVET IN
T' AMATE HINAHTANDU >>INALNDFORG
MBO E,S OWHENOHEANIN
ABIGOFPTWAON BENCTE  FEAOUS,ONI
HE  PL?INN'YOFE.Y AN
U., W WHONEYUTBUERLD
OPNG HKN YITG LYRTSB AAN DELUAEH
MA OU
RI
OUNTHVISTTO LWIN'MEORNT SR
IT E GAOTS USNGD WEWHAT HIC IIS
S AVKE TUREHAGHTH TTHCOUTA 6O YA
E O THOURUOW>>TTHT A ADERYAI, O
HE ME 'SHE E DDEVE CHE TTHDE>>T
ISAN A